know this sort of happiness movement
it's a tricky one isn't it because it's
it's a feeling like any other that comes
and goes and we can't depend on it when
so much was sort of written about
happiness as this thing that we all
needed to sort of grab and hold on to it
gave us the impression that happiness is
our default mode and anything out of
that could be a mental health problem
everyone has bad days right everyone has
days when they don't feel happy um they
feel something else and that's normal
and that's human and actually some of
the things that make us happiest also
make us feel lots of really negative and
painful emotions so i don't know like uh
well you know when you become a parent
that's the best thing in the world to
you and you feel really happy but also
there will be times when you feel really
really sad and ashamed if you feel like
you've made some mistake there's a whole
host of emotions that come along with
happiness as well so it's it's a shame
how sort of oversimplified it kind of
has been made i think